one of those guys that really hasn't quite found
a home yet but he's an effective player 15am in
nine years last year in Dallas a shot from the
corner and picker handles but always is when
you're flying that fast and you're going as quick
as McDavid does and the fast players in this game
it doesn't take a lot to get you off your Edge
and when you do is pretty hard to control it
side able to shovel it in scored the game time
oh turn over by SP it's TT Edmonton gets a gift
and I believe Conor Brown might have scored his
first goal since March of 2022 at the sh for 10
minutes concussion protocol just kidding obviously
great job by him to get to the front of the net
this is a presence Evon has had for check it is
brown that just keeps bobbling kicking slashing
at this Puck and eventually Finds Its way in he
knew it wasn't going to be pretty he's had some
great looks as of late he's been sniffing around
the net but sometimes you need a goal like this
just to bash one home now are they going to take
a look at this as goenda Kane does have a bump
on them and I got to tell you they're going to
challenge New Jersey is challenging the play for
goenda Kan when he takes his line to the front of
the net there's going to be a couple things we're
going to have to look at here when we look at the
overhead if we can was he in the blue paint when
he made the contact if you watch the left skate
of Vander Kane he actually takes this puck now it
hasn't come yet he's trying to not make contact
it's a little bit later but it does go off of
his skate but for me it is in the blue paint
he does have contact after video review it's
determined that the Edmonton player was in the
crease causing contact with the goalie we have
no goal come to grips of that fact although they
just took it off Andre palot will send it over to
brat play mind deir with a quick shot short side
basically asking are you sure in metaphorical
terms Brown to dry put it out front that one off
the skate of hon it could be a three-on-one for
New Jersey here's Jesper Brad loads fire save pick
her to the rebound T line hman will give it up nen
Hopkins to McDavid backs his way in against Colin
Miller in fact sent Miller to the ice with that
move in front whatever to save and the rebound
tapped wide the New Jersey Ben scramble back to
the bench here turnover in front Derek Ryan had
it sloted away rebound Hamlin didn't get a shot
through Ryan fire save SP rebound hin fourth line
all kinds of pressure and the devil's able to boot
it out Nathan Bas is sended in Devils lost him
for a time to Seattle on waivers got him back
Lazar nits a shot and that stayed out you don't
see a team a couple times a year it's like when
was that wired R here's a shot off the rush and
a stop on Kane who draws a penalty he's pretty
fast himself and then on the ice up it's dryo
you saw that long look on the backhand side the
best guy when he has in that position to find
someone threads it right through to Kane gets
a good look Hyman had it stripped BL sh to step
up tried to swing it down low Kane fre to McDavid
darted inside One D A stop by head getting out
of this not a really aggressive penalty kill
once in formation but big bodies long reaches and
just continuing to get sticks and that's the best
chance so far and Akira Schmid with a real good
save on dry side stay out D devs had a chance to
clear there did not get it done and now McDavid
hits the byid point they create some good chances
here this is actually a real nice play and sound
play to keep it alive by Bru Shard that will quick
pass by McDavid that's a good look for dry CLE
good blocker save for Schmidt as he stands his
ground 6'5 he's a big guy he he looked like he
had a lane to the net but he was looking back
door just a little bit for red rection who was
tied up nicely in front of the net couldn't get
a handle on it derck Ryan back to Bret kulak now
G in front Ryan Thor over the left pad ofid and
Edmonton takes the one nothing lead on Ryan's
third fourth line goes out for Evon this is
a real solid shift up against the heer line and
a lot could say that's the top line for the New
Jersey Devils when you look at the situations AER
plays in but work it down low funnel retrieval and
again great work behind the net Sam D protects
this Puck takes a quick little look that little
pass the Ryan gets the shot away beating the
check of heer and it finds its way home for
a one- nothing lead the Nur thirdd power play
the afternoon for Edmonton as the Oilers look
for separation and what has been a hard fought
and often airtight hockey game rys last boost
Hardy score stay hot Evan Bard a Howitzer two
nothing 99 Plus on that one it's Michael McLoud
that gets in the shooting Lane here if you watch
him and he has to get it just by McLoud to still
keep it on neck and this is the area that I think
Evan Bard is St toel at it's a bomb I mean boom
he lets this thing go tickles the Rapters lets
the B bomb go but it's the accuracy and I know
Chris noblock talked about it not many guys have
that combination not just the pace the jack Now
Kevin ball steps up Marino will trade places with
him drag it around fogu used to BU the screen side
door s in and what a save by picker Point Blank
that was the only lane that was open that's where
he's become so good at letting that shot go and
getting it through I'm just saying in general it
makes you think twice here's a steal hman denied
scorpion save Schmid he got it with the right pad
it me is it was McLoud that kind of clipped
McDavid earlier in the game and put him down
so maybe that's why he's running around giving
him shots he didn't like that little BMB easy
save for picker EOL has hman and that clipped off
his stick so it won't be icy but it doesn't lead
to a breakaway smid got caught however it's for
tap in McDavid three nothing smid got caught in
no man's land and Conor McDavid won't ever score
an easier goal but this is all zackman here get
in the for che he's at the end of his shift you
know they're tired they stay out he battles in
there sticks around great support by Evander
Kan who eventually fishes this Puck out and
finds McDavid late in the shift and this is where
McDavid especially hman here on this shift they'll
take in the deep water on a shift and eventually
they'll pounce when you're in a change you think
everything's okay Conor McDavid gets to the front
of the net untouched and jams this one home I like
Sly though they off with Darnell nurse to Evander
Kan three nothing for Edmonton mcdavid's 10 from
Kane andman McDavid now with a nine game point
streak back door and the devils are right back
in it and there's jper brat who was overdue he
spoils the shut out bit for Calvin Pickard and
it's game on 3-1 with 1507 to play Jersey he's
been their best player and he's been all over
it little regroup tap and then eventually it's
going to be a hard cross pass that play broken
up and it goes off the stick just good hands to
get a piece of this a hard OneTouch pass and then
for Brad all he can really do is just stay strong
on the stick and Ricochet it through and it finds
the back of the net no chance for Calvin picker on
that one drar to eliminate that ice is close Jack
Hugh has a step on Races comes the right shoulder
save Hugh went down this time there is no call and
McDavid absolutely leveled Miller tries settled to
Kane back to tries on redirect it and McDavid shot
was stopped by Schmid because nit does not look
like a guy who needs more ahlc and you know for
a fact that's exactly where Hamilton would be
to Foley down low with a sand kick Point BL he
robbed Hughes Jack that is Nurse able to poke it
back to Center probably picker's best save of the
day steuart Skinner he got a standing ovation
from this backup goalie tonight he loved that
save McDavid with an empty net the steel Kane will
fire it home and that will put this game to bed 41
Edmonson get it tonight as an Oiler Stones
them and then the other way the play pick
pocket by MCD with the spin P Hamlin
wins one final faceof kulak skates out
the remainder of the clock 4-1 Edmonson
that's your final seven in a row at home